welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and thor forward director taika
watiti
just revealed a ton of details about the
love and thunder plot while hosting an
instagram live watch along of thor
ragnarok the forever on filmmaker had
plenty of bits
including a hilarious fake thor for
script page showing tony stark's
resurrection
and launch of the avengers but also some
concept art showing meek with feminine
android legs and attire
and the town of new asgard in norway
including a new tavern named after
thor's hammer mjolnir
but tt also confirmed other details like
silver surfer and doctor strange not
appearing in the movie beta ray bill
maybe making a cameo
and thor getting back in shape from his
lebowski form and end game but for me
what tt's biggest reveal concerned loki
can't get enough of this guy
because the existence of the god of
mischief in a future mcu property is
kind of a bellwether for how raging the
party's gonna be oh wait loki's gonna be
there oh [ __ ] yeah let me get my horns
the fact that loki is one of the few
major marvel characters
to die on screen not temporarily dust
from existence but then come back but
actually
live leak nsfl r.i.p and then not
resurrect in the main mcu timeline like
gamora did
indicates to us that any loki appearance
must mean certain things for that story
setting and premise by that i mean the
laws of nature must have been
ignored or changed so let us break down
what tt's social media clues with
another new rock star's tweet then
uh wait this was on instagram instagram
so what's easy was asked about loki
multiple times during the live stream
and he claimed he had no
idea that marvel intended to kill off
loki in infinity war did i know when i
made this movie that loki would be
killed off in infinity war
i'd had no idea had no idea about any of
that
uh what happens at marvel we don't
really tend to share a lot of stuff
you know i might have if for example
i had said while making ragnarok we
should kill
loki then because of their plans for the
rest of films they may have just said no
we need him
for the next thing so that's sort of as
far as it goes really like they don't
don't share like a lot of the scripts
and we don't like kind of get too
involved in each other's films
um so yeah there's like kevin and
victoria and lou they
they sort of oversee their stuff and
keep everyone in their lane even more
cryptic was watiti's response when asked
about loki's possible return in thor 4.
we get an appearance from loki and love
and thunder
[Music]
can't say interesting like he could have
said no
or no comment or just ignore the
question but what tg definitely seems to
be leaving the door open to whether
loki's gonna be at this party which yeah
is weird because in order for loki to
even possibly appear something very
bizarre must be going down in the
universe of thor 4. like loki being in
the loki series on disney plus makes
sense since we saw him escape on his own
branch timeline from the time
heist and endgame and now his jumpsuit
tells us he's in trouble with the tva
the time variance authority marvel's
time cops who oversee alternate timeline
hopping yeah all that checks out but
thor
4 we assumed was going to take place
post end game
in the mcu prime present day after the
asgardian refugees have resettled a new
asgard
built a mjolnir tavern five or six years
or so after
loki died in infinity war and like died
died so what does loki's
maybe appearance in thor 11 thunder tell
us about this movie's plot well i see
three theories for how this could work
31 all of the marvel phase 4 movies will
take place in
alternate universes that's right no more
primary mcu timeline or if there is
that's not where this is it could be
possible that after the avengers allowed
the timeline to be disrupted in some
major ways and end game like letting
loki get away thanos and his forces
leading a void in 2014
tap creating a new branch history with
peggy carter also the fact that they
stole pym particles without replacing
them and then hawkeye stole his kid's
glove
all of these variances caused the mcu
timeline to splinter into a spectrum
and several of the mcu films we see will
take place
in different alternate realities 4 4
could be set in a reality in which loki
did not die but
also in a reality in which hella did not
shatter mjolnir
because let's remember it makes no sense
for jane foster to wield mjolnir in the
prime post end game timeline
if it was obliterated in 2017 of that
timeline i mean this could be used to
explain a lot of inconsistencies like
black widow black widow could be set in
reality in which natasha did have a
family before the avengers which might
be why she told captain endgame that
before the avengers she had no family
when in black widow she
does have a kind of family that
alternate timeline stuff could also
explain why thaddeus ross appears to be
de-aged in some of the black widow promo
footage like
what's going on there the answer
multiverse essentially rather than all
of their movies existing in one
elaborate
interconnected universe marvel could
just avoid that complexity and now tell
stories that don't have to set up other
stories
and thor love and thunder could just be
whatever tycooa tt thor
and loki and valkyrie and gore story
that he wanted to tell infinity war be
damned
but i hear your screams that
interconnectivity is also marvel's bread
and butter it's
their whole business model so let us
consider theory two loki returns to the
main mcu timeline after
time hopping with the tva in the loki
series on disney plus
this could just be as simple as gamora's
return to the mcu after her death in
infinity war she's an alternate past
version of herself just like loki's an
alternate past version of himself and he
could use the technology the tva
to navigate to the timeline spectrum
back to the prime timeline where we all
are but the same way that gamora is now
a darker version of herself who never
went through the experiences of
guardians vol 1 and 2
this loki never had their redemptive
experiences of thor the dark world or
ragnarok or infinity war really the
ultimate cost of these characters deaths
is that they've been stripped back down
to their most
undeveloped selves i don't really mind
that because avengers loki and guardians
act 1 gamora were
still super fun to watch but they both
now have a bit of that captain america
syndrome characters out of their times
missing out on references
really the most exciting reveal from
what tt's watch along is how
insane he's making thor 4 sound rather
than a movie bound by the rules and
logic of the mcu
watiti described thor 4 as so over the
top in the best way
it makes ragnarok seem like a really
run-of-the-mill very safe film
this new film feels like we asked a
bunch of 10 year olds what should be in
a movie and just said yes to everything
yeah i don't imagine
10 year olds pitching confusing time
travel logic so with this in mind the
version of loki's return that excites
the kid in me
is one that brings back the same loki
that left us look folks if i've been
looking or sounding differently more
blue on me than usual it's because
current events have kind of trapped us
on our own individual little bubbles
and now more than ever we're looking for
ways to connect with each other
digitally and safely one of the best
ways
we've been using to get through this is
house party thanks to house party for
sponsoring this video
house party is a group video chat app
that allows groups of up to eight people
to chat face to face at the same time
users can also play games compete in
trivia or play ellen degeneres's heads
up game
use my link below to download the house
party yourself
so here's uh off-screen producer zack
i'm sure you see him he thinks he's so
smart
we're gonna do some trivia trivia about
fortnite how about general knowledge
what determines how loud a volume at the
door i'm pretty sure that's where you
have uh irritable bowel syndrome right
heart system
that's how you play right now we're all
looking for more ways to connect with
friends and family and house party is a
really great option
they built the app to be the most human
way to be together when not together
it's simple enough for anybody to figure
out and it's a lot of fun house party is
free to download and available on ios
android mac os and chrome use my link
below to download the house party
yourself
and thanks to epic games for sponsoring
this video okay theory three
loki resurrects after his death in a
wild
mythological revenge tale from hell what
happened to loki when thanos snapped his
neck well perhaps he followed the
ragnarok mythology and respawned
somewhere
otherwise his destination would be
valhalla or hell
hell would be a dominion ruled over by
hella right who also might have dropped
down there after
losing a serter in ragnarok maybe the
reason jane foster has to take over for
thor and love and thunder
is because our brother gets slain by
gore the godbutcher a guy who carries a
celestial killing all black the necker
sword which we just ranked as the most
powerful weapon in the mcu
that would mean thor and loki and hella
all in the norse afterlife of hell
and let's say loki figures out a way to
escape the concept
are drawn up for infinity war but never
used but you know what tt's going to
want to bring back the carcass of the
great
jormungunder the midgard snake they
awaken the snake in and ride that
hellbeast back into the realm of the
living i mean that's like a crazy 10
year old plot
they can imagine with tt being a bit
hesitant to spell out in a live stream
really what td's ultimate troll could be
that that tony stark resurrection script
page was actually real dialogue but just
with different character names
look folks i think the mcu is going
straight to hell because hell
is just another multiverse dimension
folks maybe we'll finally go there in
one division or multiverse of madness
and then we get to open the floodgates
to demonic entities like mephisto
nightmare ghost rider loki and his giant
snake kind of [ __ ] you're gonna need
blade to take down like if you asked 10
year old me to make a movie about gods
and superheroes a 10 year old eric voss
traumatized from blade event horizon
spawn what dreams may come and a
catholic education would probably just
whimper
what if it's hell what if everything's
hell
are we in hell is this hell i want to go
to hell
how do you think loki should return in
thor love and thunder comment down below
with your thoughts and join our mcu
watchalongs on discord by becoming a
patron at patreon.com
new rockstars new rockstars discord is a
magical place where i give fun
challenges to our patrons like trying to
find the three beetlejuice easter eggs
that were
really hidden in the last video shout
out to mitsuolova who found the first
two
and composer95 who was able to find the
third it's a real group effort there
good job guys follow me at eavos follow
new rockstars
and subscribe here on youtube for the
dark wishes
[Music]
you